[Musique]
j'ai acquis mortel à ses accès et qui
fait là je sais que tu hésites entre
l'adjectif translucide et succulent
c'était trans culot à m'accepter voix ce
soir comedy club je pars 60 ans 12 euros
excuse moi j'étais ravie je vous dis moi
ok pas de script du mois 2 euros
khartoum espèces
j'avais près mais tp ce matin mais je
crois que c'est bon sans contact tu peux
aussi frérot
devra payer boulevard ghandi je t'invite
dans la vie ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire
accepte l'invitation donc tu viens j'ai
accepté l'invitation psg ouvert mon
affaire tu es mon poto tunnel se tient
justement fait on peut donc pas de débat
six étages quand même deux balles
et pas de ne pas que la fille ma
mère sera prise elle a vite ta mère je
papilles deux bacs c'est non mais
attends ton temps qu'elle tue ses 4 me
dégoûte et a fait la tournée des vers 6
heures les aînés tout est bankable du
cinéma frère je suis pas ton frère
antoine armes en toute chose quelque
part tu peux acheter ce dont on parle
avec ma mère je vais acheter ce quelque
part et je vais te mettre dehors tu m'a
invité je t'ai dit je viens tu m'as dit
fait une pub chez fait une pub mais il
m'a dit fais une story je fais une story
mais bien vite tes amis célèbres
j'invite tous mes amis c'est laisse
bercer nagui est là maintenant tu vas me
faire payer 12 balles mais personne ne
sait combien ça coûte toutes ces pubs
normalement donc j'aime ça coutu émile
basly ses coutumes il va auquel je
soustrais les douze balles et un match
et on calcule
ouais c'est ça que tu me dois cloud doit
7980 guibal bon je te rejoins hâte alors
et j'attends mais 7020
[Musique]